sean efe de igual a logaritmo natural de
temas 3 y hd tm igual a t cuadrada menos
5 t2 las gráficas de ye igual a efe dt y
de iguala hd tm están aquí abajo de lujo
observa aquí en verde tengo la función
de jane igual
efe dt es esto de aquí es decir ye igual
al logar y tu natural de temas tres
justos como definimos a efe dt y también
tengo esta gráfica de azul que es la
gráfica de james igual a http muy bien
después dicen cuáles de las opciones
siguientes parecen ser soluciones de
logaritmo natural de temas 3 igual a t
cuadrada menos 5 t2 elige todas las
opciones correctas así que te encargo
que pausa es el vídeo e intente resolver
esto por ti mismo piensa en cuáles son
las opciones correctas
bueno pues otra forma de pensarlo es la
siguiente logaritmo natural de temas 3
eso es lo mismo que ft aquí lo tenemos y
por otra parte de cuadrada menos cinco
temas 2 esto es lo mismo que hd tm es la
definición de hdt es decir estamos
buscando las 3 para las cuales ft es
igual a hd te vamos a buscar todas las
test que cumplan esa igualdad y bueno
cualquier t que cumpla esa igualdad se
va a encontrar en los puntos de
intersección todas las 3 que hagan a efe
de igual a htc son las tres que van a
estar en los puntos de intersección así
que vamos a buscarlos por ejemplo este
de aquí para empezar vamos a pararnos en
el punto de 3,73 y bueno este punto de
kim observa que está tanto en ft como en
hd tm por lo tanto este es un punto en
donde ft es igual a h
y ambas toman el valor de 3 otra forma
de decirlo es que entre igual de 3 ft es
igual a hd tm las dos funciones son
iguales en este punto así que tendríamos
que elegir
esta de 3 muy bien ya que la
seleccionamos ahora regresemos a este
punto y vamos a buscar otro punto de
intersección
si me sigo por aquí llego hasta este
punto de aquí al punto de 4,74 observa
este también es un punto de intersección
es decir que si me fijo en ft 4 eso va a
ser igual a 4 y si me fijo en hd de 4
también va a ser de 4 por lo tanto en
este punto de intersección en 74 va a
ser igual a h t4 o bueno otra forma de
verlo es la siguiente si sustituimos atp
por t 4 en esta igualdad que tengo aquí
esta igualdad se cumpliría
es decir el logaritmo natural de t
subíndice 4 más
es exactamente lo mismo que te subíndice
4 al cuadrado menos 5 veces este
subíndice 42 esta igualdad se cumpliría
en este punto en el punto de subíndice
4,10 subíndice 4 así que también es hora
de seleccionar at4 muy bien y si nos
fijamos ya no tenemos otro punto de
intersección este no es un punto de
intersección porque solamente pertenece
a efe de éste tampoco es un punto de
a htc y entonces los únicos dos son el
punto de 3,73 y el punto de 4,4 por lo
tanto parece ser que ya acabamos así que
es momento de comprobar respuesta y de
lujo estamos bien